- Bon matin!
- À 84 ans, Yolande Chartier
poursuit sa carrière d'agente
immobilière, avant  a a a a a as
en plus pour des motifs
financiers. Une partie
de ses économies a fondu;
elle doit dé
YOLANDE CHARTIERcocourtière
immobilière, RE/MAX Québec
- On va regarder ce qu'il y a
sur le marché.ananananananananaà
l'âge que j'ai, je peux être
obligée ararrêter de travailler
demain matin.
Alors, j'ai deux quatre et demi
en hasasasasasasasasasasasasasat
en arrière. Moi, il me reste
lele premier.
- Ses immeubles à logements
la gardent à flot, mais elle se
de gâter ses petits-enfants
comme elle le souhaite.
- Quand je serai morte...
j'en n'ai plus de besoin, moi,
là. C'est là que j'ai besoin
eux-autres, puis de les voir
heureux.
placements perdre de 10 à 20 %
de leur valeur en moyenne
depuis six mois.
- C'est beaucoup, là,
- Cette planificatrice
nanancière voit de plus en plus
de gens reporter leur projet
de retraite, en attenteababababé
financière. Faute de solution
miracle, la patience
est de mise.
KARINE BÉGUIN,rerererererererere
- Suite à une crise,
àà une baisse, idéalement,
on fait pas de rachat, on change
rien dans le portefeuille,isisir
la perte. Donc, on attend
que ça revienne.
- À 73 ans, Lorraine Mougeot
fait de la suppléance DaDaDaDaD,
le travail est plutôt
une nécessité.
Votre perspective de retraite?
LORRAINE MOUGEléléléléléléléléls
- J'en ai pas. J'aimerais
continuer à travailler
pour assurer ma survie autant..e
l'ont empêchée d'économiser
pour ses vieux jours. Les rentrt
insuffisantes pour payer
son logement à Montréal-Nord,
là où elle peut s'adonner
à son passe-temps favatatatatat.
- Dans le fin fond, je suis
inquiète, parce que je me dis :
s'il m'arrive un gros problème
de santé et quimimimimimimimimi,
où est-ce quEtEtEtEtEtEtEtEtEtEe
dans sa situation : environ
un Canadien sur trois n'a pas
GISÈLE TASSÉ-GOODMAN,
présidente, Réseau FADOQ
c'est la prestation
de la Sécutété de la vieillesse
et le Supplément de revenu
garanti.
bonifier de 10 % la Sécurité
deieieillesse dès juillet,
mais seules les personnes
de 75 ans et plus y seront
- Comment se fait-il
qu'on maintient toujours
que ce n'est pas... ce n'est pas
nécessaire, qu'ils n'ont pas
pertinemment bien
que la précarité financière,
elle est bien réelle chez
ces personnes-là et que c'est
bouts à la fin du mois.
voit son avenir sur le marché
du travail pour conserrr
ses petits bonheurs.
lelelelelelelelelelelelelelelels
reprennent du poil de la bête.
- Bonne journée! Merci,
à vendredi, au revoir.ghghghghg,
Radio-Canada, Montréal